If you are a film buff, you should be familiar
with the early Soviet movie Battleship Potemkin
and its iconic scene of a pram rolling down
a staircase, as soldiers shoot down protesters.
The film is centred around the Russian Revolution
of 1905 and directed by cinematic legend Sergej
Eisenstein.
Eisenstein would later direct ‘October’,
a retelling of that other uprising -- the
successful one -- the Russian Revolution of
1917.
This film features our protagonist of today,
Alexander Kerensky, depicted as a pompous,
poor man’s Napoleon, his image juxtaposed
with that of a mechanical peacock.
Kerensky was portrayed as a clear symbol of
artificial vanity.
This unflattering portrayal reflects the Bolsheviks’
opinion of Kerensky, who in modern times has
been relegated to a mere footnote in the early
history of the Soviet Union.
Yet despite the Bolshevik’s perception and
Eisenstein’s clever montage techniques,
Alexander Kerensky was a revolutionary.
He had a crucial role in the overthrow of
the Tsars.
He had been a central figure in the earlier
revolution of February 1917, when he had led
the Provisional Government and sought to install
a democracy in Russia.
Did he deserve this hollow legacy?
Let’s find out in today’s Biographic about
Alexander Kerensky, the early revolutionary.
A Dancing Lawyer
Alexander Kerensky was born on May 4, 1881
in the town of Simbirsk.
This town is now known as Ul’ianovsk, after
another famous fellow who was born there 11
years earlier: Vladimir Ilic Ulianov, better
known as Lenin.
Alexander’s father was a teacher and director
of the local gymnasium, the same where Lenin
had studied.
The Kerenskys and the Ulianovs in fact were
on friendly terms, and belonged to the same
middle class intellectual circle.
In 1899, Alexander completed his studies at
the gymnasium, graduating with a gold medal
for distinction.
He had the reputation of being a polite, smart
young man.
More importantly, he was a skilled dancer
and even a gifted actor.
After high school, Kerensky enrolled at the
Law faculty of St Petersburg University, graduating
in 1904.
During the same year, he married the daughter
of a General, Olga Baranovskaia, whom I am
sure he seduced with his smooth dance moves.
Alexander and Olga later had two sons.
1905 was the year that changed everything
for the young Kerensky.
Sunday the 22nd of January became known as
Bloody Sunday – one of the too many Bloody
Sundays of human history.
Russian society was gripped in unrest, due
to the unpopularity of the Government and
the debacle of the ongoing Russo-Japanese
War.
Crowds had gathered for a peaceful demonstration
outside the Winter Palace in St Petersburg,
when the army and the police opened fire,
killing and injuring around 1,000 people.
The Revolution of 1905 continued with the
mutiny of the battleship Potemkin in June,
which inspired the film I mentioned earlier.
The resulting riots were quashed by troops
on the Tsar’s orders.
On the 30th of October, Tsar Nicholas II issued
the October Manifesto, which promised limited
civil liberties and an elected parliament,
the Duma.
In the same month, Kerensky had begun his
career as a political lawyer.
At a trial in Tallinn -- present-day Estonia
-- he defended the peasants who had ransacked
a local aristocrat’s mansion.
Kerensky continued to defend revolutionary
activists in court and joined the Aid Committee
for the victims of Bloody Sunday.
This revolutionary fervour was made clear
when he joined the Socialist Revolutionary
Party , becoming the editor of their newspaper,
Burevestnik, or The Thunderbird.
The Thunderbird was go!
Under Kerensky’s management, it increased
its circulation, but attracted the attention
of the authorities along the way.
The newspaper became the object of police
repression: the eighth issue was confiscated,
and on the 21st of December, Kerensky’s
flat was searched.
The police found incriminating evidence -- leaflets
advertising the “Armed Uprising Organization,”
which was considered to be a terrorist outfit.
Kerensky was held in custody until April 1906.
He was released due to a lack of evidence,
but the Tsarist police sent him on a ‘forced
vacation’ to Tashkent, Uzbekistan, together
with his wife Olga and their one-year-old
son Oleg.
In autumn 1906 he was allowed to return to
St. Petersburg, where he resumed his activity
as a popular lawyer, famous for his oratory
skills at political trials.
In 1910, Kerensky was the chief defender of
the Turkestan social revolutionary organization,
accused of staging armed, anti-government
acts.
The trial went well for the defendants, as
the young lawyer succeeded in preventing any
death sentences.
In 1912, he also shined as the defender of
a group of Dashnaks, Armenian activists, accused
of terrorist acts.
Storm Clouds Gather
These trials vaulted Kerensky into the political
stage of his era.
He grew in status, and in 1912 he was elected
Deputy of the Fourth State Duma from the Trudoviki,
or “Labour Group.”
He soon became the faction’s leader and
joined a freemason society to unite the anti-Tsarist
forces striving for the democratic renewal
of Russia.
His popularity grew even more when he exposed
Roman Malinovsky, an early Bolshevik leader,
as an undercover agent of the Okhrana, the
Tsar’s secret police.
In Kerensky, the young Labour movement had
found an effective leader, a vocal critic
of the Government, and one of the best speakers
on the left.
By the time World War I broke out in August
1914, Kerenski was the Duma's highest profile
radical, as well as one of the few to oppose
Russia's entrance in the conflict.
But in late 1915, Kerensky adopted a lower
profile at a Duma, as his health had declined
because of a kidney disease.
His condition continued to deteriorate, and
in April 1916, Kerensky had to go to Sweden
to have a kidney removed.
According to his grandson Stephen, he was
almost constantly on intravenous morphine
for the rest of his life.
Kerensky returned to the capital in the summer,
which had now been re-christened as Petrograd.
His stance on the war had changed.
He was now fully committed to Russia’s participation
in the war, as a means to oppose German militarism.
None of that could get Nicholas II off the
hook, though, as Kerensky continued his personal
attacks on the Tsar.
The Monarch had taken personal command of
the Armed Forces in September 1915 – something
he should have left to the professionals.
Now, everybody was against him and his poor
command skills.
By the end of 1916, Kerensky was publicly
calling for the Tsar’s abdication.
Revolution and Bad Moves
In February of 1917, Kerensky left Labour
to rejoin the Socialist Revolutionary Party.
He called again for the removal of Nicholas
II, which prompted Tsarina Alexandra to demand
that he be hanged as a traitor.
The royal family caved first.
The pressure was too much, and the Tsar abdicated
on March 13.
A Provisional Government was formed under
Prince George Lvov, who appointed Kerensky
as Minister of Justice.
The cabinet was now ruled by the Constitutional
Democrats or ‘Cadet’ party, in a tense
alliance with the more radical left.
The energic Alexander immediately abolished
capital punishment and introduced other reforms:
freedom of the press, the abolition of ethnic
and religious discrimination and even set
plans for universal suffrage.
The Provisional Government had no intention
to quit the war at this stage.
Foreign Minister Milyukov sent a note to the
Entente to inform them of this policy.
When the note became public ... the Bolsheviks,
the Soviets of the soldiers and tens of millions
of Russians were not amused, to put it mildly.
That disastrous war had rallied the people
against the Tsar, and now the Provisional
Government wanted to continue fighting.
In April the crowds were marching under the
banner, "Down with the Provisional Government".
Naturally, Milyukov was forced to resign.
The same fate befell to War Minister Guchkov,
who was promptly replaced by the charismatic
Kerensky.
Now a War Minister at the young age of 36,
Kerensky set off for Europe’s Eastern Front.
The former pacifist roused the troops in a
series of emotional speeches, appealing to
them to continue the fighting.
With his new powers, Kerensky appointed legendary
General Brusilov as the Commander in Chief
of the Russian Army.
On June 18th, the War Minister announced a
new offensive.
The July Offensive was an attack on the Austro-Hungarians
in Galician, and initially it was a great
success.
But in a repeat of many similar operations
in WWI, low morale and poor supply lines slowed
down the advance – which was then stopped
completely by German reinforcements.
Meanwhile, the Bolshevik protests against
the war forced Prince Lvov to resign as Prime
Minister.
On the 8th of July, he was replaced by the
unstoppable, still-popular Kerensky.
Ariadna Tyrkova, a member of the Constitutional
Democrat Party, commented:
"Kerensky was perhaps the only member of the
Government who knew how to deal with the masses,
since he instinctively understood the psychology
of the mob.
Therein lay his power and the main source
of his popularity"
Kerensky’s popularity extended outside of
the Russian borders.
The British and the Americans were great supporters,
too.
Mansfield Smith-Cumming, head of MI6, arranged
for his Government to receive $1.2 million
in today’s money, and the Americans sent
a similar gift.
The Spy master also sent an ‘asset’ to
keep an eye on Kerensky and ensure that he
did not sign an armistice with the Central
Empires -- none other than celebrated author
William Somerset Maugham, who back then was
on the MI6 payroll.
The novelist wrote, "The long and short of
it was that I should go to Russia and keep
the Russians in the war."
Despite Kerensky’s best efforts, the Russian
Army was melting away after the failed offensive.
Hundreds of thousands deserted, using their
weapons to seize land from the aristocracy
and forcibly redistribute it.
From this moment onward, Kerensky would execute
one bad move after the other, which would
eventually lead to the rise of Lenin and
the Soviets.
Bad
move # 1: Spark a military coup
To regain control of the Army, Kerensky fired
Brusilov and appointed General Kornilov as
Commander-in-Chief.
Kornilov did not share Kerensky’s social
and democratic views; in fact, he had plans
to restore the death penalty for soldiers
and even to militarize the factories, which
did not please the Prime Minister.
When Kerensky refused, Kornilov threatened
a military coup.
He was dismissed before ordering an army contingent
to take control of Petrograd.
Kerensky was in danger.
The only ones who could help him were his
uneasy allies, the Bolsheviks with their Red
Guards.
Lenin agreed to help, but he made it clear
that they would be fighting against Kornilov,
and not for Kerensky – an important distinction.
Bad move # 2: Arm your rivals
The request for help gave the Bolsheviks a
good reason to arm and enlist a force of 25,000
men.
They fortified Petrograd, ready for a bloody
battle, but it turned out this wasn’t needed.
A delegation of Red Guards went to meet with
Kornilov's troops, which apparently were more
chilled than Kerensky expected.
The regular army refused to attack Petrograd
and Kornilov was arrested.
Bad move # 3: Pick the wrong allies
Kerensky, who by now had a CV as long as the
Volga river, hogged another position: Supreme
Commander of the Russian Army.
Backed by British and American gold, the leader
continued with the war effort, which dented
his popularity.
On the 8th of October, Kerensky attempted
to regain some left-wing support by forming
a new coalition … but he arguably picked
the wrong allies.
He invited a majority of Mensheviks and Socialist
Revolutionaries, while the power within the
left had shifted toward Lenin’s Bolsheviks.
At Kerensky’s own earlier request, the Bolsheviks
now controlled a formidable force of 25,000
armed militiamen.
Kerensky would not be able to reassert his
authority.
To be fair to Kerensky, he was in a very difficult
position.
From the left he was threatened by the Bolsheviks,
hostile to the continuation of the war and
his support of the Mensheviks.
From the right, his Provisional Government
could still fall to the schemes of Kornilov,
who, at least according to Leon Trotsky, could
count on support from old foreign minister
Milyukov.
On October 31, 1917, Kerensky summoned agent
Somerset Maugham with a desperate request:
he had to take an urgent secret message to
British Prime Minister David Lloyd George,
appealing for weapons and ammunition.
Maugham was unimpressed by Kerensky, describing
a defeated man:
"His personality had no magnetism.
He gave no feeling of intellectual or physical
vigour."
Maugham set off immediately and two days later
he was at 10 Downing Street.
After the agent told the Prime Minister what
Kerensky wanted, Lloyd George replied:
"I can't do that.
I'm afraid I must bring this conversation
to an end.
I have a cabinet meeting I must go to."
In modern political parlance, we could assert
that Kerensky had been totally ghosted by
his supposed ‘allies.’
Back in Petrograd, the Bolsheviks had already
started to seize power.
This was the first week of November for most
of Europe, but to the Russians it was October,
hence the ‘October Revolution’.
This is because Russia still used the Julian
calendar, as opposed to the Gregorian calendar,
and lagged 13 days behind.
On the 7th of November, Kerensky was certain
that the Bolsheviks were about to seize the
capital and decided to flee.
A story began circulating about Kerensky’s
escape, but there is no confirmation: apparently
he changed into a women’s dress, either
in a nurse or servant’s uniform, and forced
his way into a car belonging to the US Embassy.
Because his car had the American flag on it,
Kerensky easily passed all Bolshevik check
points.
Later that day, the Red Guards stormed the
Winter Palace and arrested Kerensky's cabinet.
The only troops loyal to Kerensky were the
Women’s Death Battalion, some young military
cadets and a detachment of Cossacks.
After his escape, the deposed leader tried
to get the support of the Russian Army on
the Eastern Front.
Considering that this was the same Army he
had forced into a failed offensive, resulting
in mass desertions, they politely declined
his invitation to civil war.
Kerensky was more successful in rallying loyal
troops from the Northern Front.
With them, he marched toward Petrograd on
the 13th of November.
On his way to the capital Kerensky led some
Cossack troops into the barracks of Tsarkoye
Selo, a former Tsarist residence south of
Petrograd.
John Reed, American journalist and author
of ‘The 10 Days That Shook The World’
described yet another Bad Move:
Bad move # 4: Alienate all military support
Kerensky entered the town riding a white horse
at the head of his Cossacks.
At seven in the morning, he sent word to the
local rifle regiment to lay down their arms.
The soldiers replied they would remain neutral,
but would not disarm.
Kerensky gave them ten minutes to comply.
This angered the soldiers, who had been governing
themselves for eight months in an independent
Soviet.
A few minutes later, Cossack artillery opened
fire on the barracks, killing eight men.
Reed wrote:
“From that moment there were no more 'neutral'
soldiers in Tsarskoye."
Kerensky could have used a well-trained infantry
regiment for what happened next.
When Kerensky’s loyalists marched toward
Petrograd, they numbered a mere 600.
On their way, they clashed with 5000 Bolshevik
troops led by Leon Trotsky at the Battle of
Pulkovo, which could be considered the beginning
of the Russian Civil War.
Trotsky easily won the engagement, putting
an end to any attempt of armed counter-insurgency
by Kerensky.
Life in Exile
In June 1918 Alexander Kerensky, disguised
as a Serb officer, left Russia, ready to embark
on talks to organize a counter-revolution.
During the first one and a half years of his
exile, Kerensky lived in Britain, mainly in
the countryside where living costs were lower.
Later, he lived first in Prague, and then
in Paris, where he contributed to various
Russian language newspapers, editing Dni and
Novaia Rossiia.
While in France, he took part in the inconsequential
in-fighting and intrigues which plagued the
Russian exile community.
Many exiles, nostalgic of Tsarist rule, had
a deep disdain for Kerensky.
Once, a Russian woman, having noticed him
in the street in Paris, said to her child:
‘Look, Tania, here is the man who ruined
Russia’.
The Russian Civil War between the Red and
White factions was raging, but it was impossible
for Kerensky to provide full support to either
side.
While he opposed the Bolsheviks, Kerensky
did not trust the White movement as he considered
its leadership too close to General Kornilov,
his old enemy.
In 1939 Alexander and Olga Kerensky divorced,
and in the same year he married a former Australian
journalist Lidia Tritton.
When the Germans occupied France in June 1940,
Kerensky and Lidia fled to the US, where he
resumed his activities as a journalist and
writer.
When Hitler attacked the Soviet Union in June
1941, Kerensky offered his support to Stalin.
I don’t know what type of answer he was
expecting, but what he got was absolutely
logical.
[Editing note: show image of tumbleweed with
‘swooshing’ wind sound effect]
Ghosted.
Undeterred, Kerensky established radio transmissions
to the USSR to support the military effort.
After the war, he organized the “Union for
Russia’s Liberation,” presumably to restore
a less extremist regime in Russia, but this
did not achieve any results.
When his wife Lidia fell terminally ill in
1945, he took her to Brisbane, Australia and
they lived with her family until her death
in February 1946.
He then returned to the States, living in
both New York and at Stanford University,
in California, where he taught Russian history.
On April 24, 1970 Kerensky was admitted into
hospital in New York, to recover from a broken
elbow and pelvis sustained in a fall.
At age 89, he did not recover, and on the
11th of June he died of heart disease, or
cancer, depending on the sources.
Even after his dying moments, this was a man
who would elicit strong reactions.
According to his grandson, there were some
nurses in the hospital staff of Russian origin
and they refused to touch him, because they
held him responsible for starting the revolution.
The local Russian Orthodox Church refused
to bury him as they considered him to be a
freemason, and the man behind Tsarist Russia’s
fall.
The local Serb Orthodox Church also refused
to bury him.
His body was moved to London and buried at
Putney Vale cemetery, London, where he had
spent the very first part of his exile and
where his sons lived.
Legacy
For 12 years, Alexander Kerensky had been
a skilled lawyer, a brilliant orator, and
a well-rounded politician who at a very young
age had covered many important posts.
His moderate democratic socialism, while calling
for the abolition of the Tsar’s rule, was
a needed balancing element for the Bolshevik
excesses.
And yet, because of what he did in only four
months – from July to October 1917 -- he
would be shunned by revolutionaries and reactionaries
alike, mocked for his supposedly Napoleonic
ambitions and generally portrayed as a failure.
Some historians even believe that rather than
fearing a military coup by his enemy Kornilov,
Kerensky was actually manipulating the General
to create his own dictatorship as a countermeasure.
His limited inquiries into Kornilov’ fail
bid sparked suspicions that he may have had
authoritarian intentions.
Perhaps the reason for Kerensky’s failure
in Government was best explained by British
politician and journalist Morgan Philips Price.
In the Manchester Guardian of 19th November
1917, he wrote:
“The Government of Kerensky fell before
the Bolshevik insurgents because it had no
supporters in the country.
The bourgeois parties and the generals and
the staff disliked it because it would not
establish a military dictatorship.
The Revolutionary Democracy lost faith in
it because after eight months it had neither
given land to the peasants nor established
State control of industries, nor advanced
the cause of the Russian peace programme”
In other words: Kerensky was caught between
two opposing factions that were held together
only by a common enemy: the rule of Tsar Nicholas
II.
In an attempt to keep them together, Kerensky’s
bad moves had alienated all potential support,
while arming his most motivated rivals Lenin
and Trotsky.
The February Revolution led to the October
Revolution, which led to the Soviet Union,
the longest running totalitarian state in
Europe – and to the Cold War.
It begs the question: what could have Russia
and the rest of the world been, had Kerensky
made a few different choices?
That’s all
for today, please like and subscribe and usual
… thank you for watching!